qu'est ce que c'est qu'une femme pour
loïc 15 ans et demi en troisième au
lycée champollion grenoble ça peut être
là la campagne de la vie pourquoi ça
peut être ça pourrait ne pas l'être
ce serait quoi
c'est un être humain alors mon petit que
l'homme s'ils se marient pas pourquoi si
elle se marie
il
si elle se marie dans les conditions
actuelles qu'elle peut pas être l'égal
de l'homme dans le mariage pourquoi les
structures sociales sont faites de telle
façon que
que la femme va être l'égal de l'homme
elle devient quoi alors
elle est quoi à ce moment là dans mon
nom est une machine à faire des enfants
pas tout à fait mais presque la servante
de l'homme
est ce que vous êtes d'accord extrême
pas non pas du tout carlina 15 ans et
demi comme louis depuis l'âge de 15 ans
3 mois comme toutes les jeunes filles
caroline à la possibilité légale de se
marier
maintenant on peut dire tout me marier
maintenant et pourquoi parce que je suis
pas encore assez stable toute façon nous
faudrait il faudrait que j'ai influencé
ou un ami mais de toute façon c'est
ridicule de commencer sa vie à kazan
mais vous me dites que c'est ridicule
mais vrai ça va est-ce que vous
prendriez vous mariez maintenant oui
peur de pas pouvoir vivre pendant 40 ans
avec le même homme sans savoir sans
savoir vraiment que je l'aimais que que
je pourrais je pourrais vivre avec lui
laurie france vendeuse dans un petit
magasin de tissus 15 ans juste qu'est ce
que c'est un mari pauvres c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui restera toujours au
près de meaux qui quand même à marcher
le ménage non parce que c'est quand même
assez rôle de la femme mais qui tiendra
quand même une grande partie dans ma vie
quel est son rôle alors
puis doit faire son travail
moi je trouve que dès qu'il a fini ceci
doit rentrer à la maison mais une pu
rien faire ce n'est pas son rôle de
s'occuper du ménage des enfants doit
trouver ménage fait le repas tout prêts
trouver un fruit calme entrants est ce
que le mariage pour vous c'est une façon
de devenir une femme
c'est à dire libre ou est ce que ce
n'est pas une prison pour vous non c'est
la façon une façon de devenir plus libre
bien je suis déjà beaucoup j'ai pas je
me mets dans l'idée que d'être mariée je
serai encore beaucoup plus libre c'est
peut-être bête mais moi est ce que vous
estimez avoir au fait que c'est
nécessaire d'avoir des expériences
sexuelles avant le mariage
pas pour une femme pourquoi parce que
dans mon idée moi j'ai envie de rester
pur pour mon mari mais les garçons alors
c'est quoi ces différentes vous ne sera
pas pur lui will genia je trouve que
qu'un garçon quand même a besoin d'avoir
des deux liaisons
c'est tout à fait naturel
[Musique]
non vous vous voyez vous dans quinze ans
marié avec des enfants pourquoi vous
pousser un soupir qu'on aimerait que je
reste et un âge de 18 ans on aimerait
plus objet ne pas avoir 30 ans dit on
vieillit dire c'est terrible pour un oui
et pourquoi pas je vois toujours rester
jeune même ces voix là mais je voudrai
toujours 18 ans mais plus vieillir je
trouve que dès qu'on atteint la
trentaine même en atteignant la 19 ans
ayant dit ça y est c'est fini on
vieillit elle s'appelle odile son père à
une ferme deux hectares à 50 kilomètres
de grenoble
il faut l'imaginer aller et venir dans
la ferme tous les jours avec sa mère
c'est elle qui mène la maison j
vous y avez pensé n'ont pas beaucoup pas
encore pourquoi vous n'avez pas pensé
encore mariage vous trouvez trop jeune
et trop jeune la cage voulez vous marier
17 18 ans et mariage c'est quoi vos
basses et lorsque l homme et une femme
sont réunis pour toute leur vie alors
d'un pass quitter ta rester le rester un
simple puis c'est fait pour faire une
famille qu'est ce qu'un homme
pour moi un homme c'est quelqu'un qui
est supérieur à la femme les il est
destiné aux travaux des champs ou plus
durs travaux
et puis un arrêt normalement quand il a
des enfants ils sont plus d'une
responsable un petit enfant quand même
est-ce que vous croyez que marie dans
ménages ça doit faire la vaisselle
non je ne pense pas laver le linge des
enfants non je pense que ce rôle est
attribué plutôt à la femme
vous pensez pas que dans une famille on
pourrait partager les rôles comme ça et
en vol pourraient se partager mais
comment un homme n'est pas destiné pour
faire la lessive et la vaisselle nicole
c'est un travail dans une petite usine
de grenoble
nicole et henry sont fiancés depuis
décembre ils se marieront quand henry
aura fait son service militaire
les problèmes sont simples l'argent le
logement dans la ville il ya des
difficultés on est là pour les résoudre
par rapport à carolina odile à marie
france nicolas beaucoup plus qu'un an de
plus
comment vous avez distribué les rôles
qu'est ce que vous ferez vous qu'est-ce
qui fera lui ce qui fera lui ben bon
premièrement si travail si on travaille
tous les deux on y rentre à 20 quand tu
rentreras on se partagera le s'il ya du
ménage à faire tout ça on se partagera
quoi lui fera la vaisselle ou moi je
fais la chambre où quelque chose une
contraire qu'on se remarier avec
conquest on continuerait à travailler
oui je pense que oui parce que tant
qu'on n'aura pas d'enfant coin
continuera quoi pour ré déménagent parce
que je suis trop bien obligé et puis
pour un être plus vite avoir plus
d'affaires plus vite quoi
mais quand vous avez des enfants vous ce
serait de travailler
sachez pas céder pas combien je gagnerai
par mois si ça me revient pas plus cher
je marquais j'aimerais peut faire garder
mes enfants parce que on met des
informations les élèves pas alors je
trouve que c'est pas bien
est ce que vous allez vrai les faits
comme les garçons la même façon oui oui
enfin vous voulez dire sans préférence
pour l'un ou l'autre
alors c'est pas ça non mais je vais de
la même façon à ce que vous sais pas
s'il est pauvre et faire des études ou
garçon efféminé aussi tous pareil si on
peut si on peut se permettre de payer
des études ou garçons comme l a si bien
sûr mais si vous pouviez pas vous
permettre de payer des études aux
garçons et aux filles
quand vous choisiriez ça je sais pas on
fera peut-être comme mes parents ont
fait enfin faire est étudié par exemple
le garçon en premier et puis que le gars
ont travaillé que la fille faith ses
études kwapis travailler après chacun
son tour oui est ce que vous pensez que
une femme doit avoir des idées
politiques et s'occuper de politique
oui parce qu'une femme a beaucoup à dire
sur certains sur certaines choses et
elle voit peut-être mieux le problème
qu'un garçon les problèmes politiques ou
le problème de sa déco syndicaux
politiques et pourquoi le fameux voit
mieux les choses car son jeu pas moins
la petite l'esprit plus large
et des shows une femme s'occupe beaucoup
plus de choses qu'un homme
par exemple même pour juste dans le
ménage même si l'homme est de la maison
tout ceci me semble que c'est pas pareil
les femmes elles ont certaines choses
avaient en faire une indication à
démontrer enfin voir quoi et les hommes
autre chose pas tout à fait de même dans
une même ligne quoi exemple d'abord pour
ce travail - un homme il pourra
peut-être faire neuf heures par jour la
femme elle devrait on dire que cette
parce qu'elle a son ménage de s'occuper
[Musique]